killed in an Israeli strike three
sisters aged between 10 and 14 remas
delin and lean their grandmother also
dead they were in their car as it was
being driven a few kilometers from
lebanon's border with Israel their
grandfather
inconsolable their mother was wounded in
the attack she isn't here her condition
is
serious Israel's military claimed their
vehicle was suspected of being used to
transport what it described as
terrorists this is the aggressive
behavior of the Zionist enemy and we are
used to this Israel claims there were
resistance fighters in the car but they
were children and their
mother relatives say the children were
on their way to Beirut when the car was
hit their uncle was in another vehicle
and witnessed the strike he watched the
children and his mother burn inside
while his wounded sister their mother
was screaming where are my children 10
civilians have been killed by Israeli
fire since crossborder fighting in
response to Israel's war on Gaza began
more than a month ago the children and
their grandmother were the latest
casualties they were killed 2 days after
hezbollah's leader Hassan nah warned
that for every civilian killed in
Lebanon a civilian would be killed in
Israel the Waring sides had been largely
focusing attacks on Military targets
along the border
area the course of the conflict could
easily
change but for Mahmud Adnan s his life
already
has this is a father who says he has
nothing left zenah Al jazer Southern
Lebanon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer